thanks for joining us America Chris is
with us in Washington DC hey Chris how
are you hey Dave I'm doing good
really appreciate what you do is you
know them listening to you for a long
time and you know I can't say that I
follow all the rules and I hope only to
take him to the woodshed too badly but
you've definitely changed my family's
life for the better
cool cool how can I help today sure
so long story short my wife and I sold a
house that we had on the market for
about a year and we took all of the
equity that we had we have another
mortgage in the house that we live in
but we paid off all of our debt except
for the $30,000 of student loans or so
that we have so we have have an envelope
budgeting system that we try to adhere
to pretty well every month but we have
about $30,000 we could pay the student
loans off today but we would not any
longer have like our 90-day slush fund
so I'm trying to decide if I should
write a $20,000 check to pay off what I
can today and keep another 10,000 or so
set aside for our 90 day of emergency
fund or if I should continue paying what
we've budgeted which is $1,000 a month
and then write a check when I can just
pay it off in a single lump sum I'm
basically afraid to let go of the money
that we've got right now you know it's
so that's kind of my question to you
what's your household income a little
over two hundred thousand okay and so
why would you only be paying $1,000 a
month on this I would say that you know
a few years is acceptable for us yeah
that's that's kind of beautiful
in other words yeah and you knew that
you knew that how do I have to point it
out you already knew that was coming
as we do we're putting you know about
$2,000 a month in 401k no and that's
okay now let's let's stop you said
earlier in the conversation that you
listen have been listening to me for a
good while yes sir okay so it ought to
be fairly easy for you the only question
is are you gonna do your plan are you
gonna do the plan not teach either ones
okay you're not a dumb guy you make
$200,000 you're gonna be all right
you're not gonna go bankrupt
but if you're gonna work our plan you
know what that plan is right it would be
to cut some of our lifestyle choices so
that we could pay it off now and save up
our our money know save up to 90 days as
low as we could no you flunked the test
okay baby step one and save $1,000 when
you start getting out of debt you clean
out all non retirement savings and you
throw it at all non mortgage debt in
baby step two so all of that says we'd
pay off the student loan 100% today
leaving you penniless making two hundred
thousand dollars a year and oh by the
way during that time we stopped and we
stopped putting money into the 401 K
until we get the emergency fund built
and we're debt-free with baby step two
and three right you heard all that
before you're not going to do it okay
but the system is no I mean it's okay
I'm not mad at you no and I'm not taking
you to the woodshed but here the process
is this what we have found is that you
have a weak foundation in your home
because you still have debt and you
don't have enough savings for somebody
that makes the money you make in your
emergency fund and so the foundation in
your financial plan is weak it's not
necessarily going to fall in because as
long as your income stays where it is
but you know so what would I do if I
woke up in your shoes is the first thing
I do before I went ahead and finish
building my house as I shore up the
foundation and so I'd write a check
today and I'd be debt-free that you're
not gonna do that but that's what I
would do and then I would stop my 401k
temporarily and
you're not gonna do that but that's what
I would do and then I would take every
dollar I can squeeze out of my budget
and I'd put $30,000 making $200,000 a
year into an emergency fund a rainy day
fund and I could do that in about five
months okay okay four or five months and
I'd have I'd have zero debt except my
home I'd have my thirty thousand dollars
and so at the end of five or six months
or whatever that ends up being I'm gonna
restart my 401k and I'm not gonna play
with anymore I'm will now put fifteen
percent of my income into retirement
which are the kind of money you make
that's gonna make you very very wealthy
that's baby step four five is kids
college I would start that or restart
that at that point and six is pay off
your house early with any of the money I
can squeeze out and what we're finding
is with all the millionaires that we've
studied the ones that have followed our
stuff are the ones that have followed
their own stuff is they do there's two
things we see them all doing they
steadily invest in their 401k and they
pay off their house early and they avoid
all other debt like the plague some of
them have a credit card much to my
chagrin I don't want them to even do
that I want them to have debit cards but
some of them actually have credit cards
but none of them carry a balance under
any circumstances ever and haven't in 30
or 40 years they pay off their home in
ten point two years on average because
they worked some semblance of what I'm
laying out here the problem in your
situation is you're trying to do too
many things at once you make really good
money and it covers up your mistakes you
know there's enough salve on this
because of the income that that you can
you know you can limp along and be okay
you'll be okay but you're not maximizing
the opportunity that's at your disposal
so you get to do what you want to do my
prediction is you're not gonna do any of
it but it's a good discussion to have
it's fine and again I'm not calling you
out it's just you know you make two
grand you don't have to do it you know
and and and you don't you know it scares
you to death and your wife will think
you're crazy if you come back in say the
announced that that's what we're gonna
do and all that's going to happen and
you
you know you're not gonna do all that
and that's okay it's okay I appreciate
having you listen anyway and hope we can
continue to entertain you